(upbeat music)
- Welcome back to another
Addy Hour episode.
As always, it's just my honor and pleasure
to continue to host these conversations.
And we do like to change
things up a little bit
in terms of the topics that we talk about.
So today we want to bring in
a conversation about immigration, culture,
faith, and mental health.
And so today I'm honored to be able
to welcome Yu-Jay Harris,
to the Addy Hour Podcast.
I'm gonna give him a
little bit of introduction
so you all know a little bit about him.
Some of you maybe familiar
with him from his book
which would be outstanding.
For those who aren't, Yu-Jay Harris is
a passionate fan of mental
and emotional health
and how it intersects with faith.
He is the President of Psychology For All,
which is a Charlotte, North
Carolina-based nonprofit
that works to drive
mental healthcare equity
and access for under-resourced people.
He's a father, an encourager,
and a contributing author
to the book "Liberia's Son"
which captures the story
of his family's resilient
journey from a civil war
in Liberia to navigating the opportunities
and challenges, and life in the US.
So I know that is
something that we'll unpack
as we go through the conversation today.
But again, just want to welcome Yu-Jay
to the program here today.
Thanks for being here, Yu-Jay.
- Thank you so much for having me, Nii.
Super proud to be part
of this opportunity.
- Thanks so much and this
has been a long time coming
in a lot of different ways.
- [Yu-Jay] Yeah.
- So good to see it
come to fruition.
I should mention, even though it pains me
as a Duke graduate to
mention that you got an MBA
from UNC Chaplain Hill.
Just kiddin'.
That is part of your path
and I know you have a BA in Psychology.
- We'll see y'all Saturday, man.
We'll see y'all Saturday.
(Nii chuckling)
We'll just leave it at that.
- [Nii] Oh my goodness.
- And I also gotta give a shout out
to my two damaging wildcats.
I'm a Davidson (audio
distortion) grad, as well.
Have some love for those people.
- Yeah, excellent, excellent.
- Thank you for allowing
me to hang out at Davidson
for the folks whoever let me in there.
(Nii chuckling)
- I think that was a
good call on their part.
So obviously, you know,
people have heard a little bit
about you in that introduction.
And we'll definitely jump into that
as the conversation unfolds.
But as you know, as my listeners know,
I do always like to check in
and just see how our guests are
doing at this point in time.
So you know we're finishing up February,
entering March of 2023.
And just wanted to ask how you're doing
at this point in time, life-wise,
and just with everything
we're navigating as a society.
- Yeah, that's a great question
and it's sort of like
how you really doin'?
This is not the just give
me the friendly answer.
Things are actually going pretty well.
The last couple of years,
as you can imagine,
were pretty interesting.
A lot of adjustments, you
know, with the pandemic,
but things are settling well.
I'm doing well.
I feel like kind of life is pretty stable
I'm gonna say drama-free, so, you know.
I jokingly say it's good
to be Yu-Jay right now.
I'm thankful for that,
so (audio distortion)
for asking, brother.
- That's good to hear.
Yeah, especially as you've
mentioned just the honesty
of having to navigate
through different things.
One thing I didn't mention
for our listeners too,
I mean, you have the Psychology
For All organization,
but then you're also the Vice President
of a customer and market
research consultancy.
So how is that journey
in terms of navigating?
And I don't know if
balancing is the right word.
I usually use the word juggling.
But how is that aspect of your life
at this point in time?
- Yeah, you know, it's interesting.
People think, 'cause I talk
about my nonprofit so much.
There are people who know me and think
that I actually, that's my full-time job
and because it is a passion of mine.
It went up from something I was doing
as a volunteer to now something
that I see more as a real necessity.
In some way, almost, it's
a ministry, you know,
to use of a term.
But it's great.
My corporate job sort of
gives me, it allows me
to sort of apply my skills as a marketer
and someone who likes to
solve business problems
and then sort of manage
relationships in terms of clients.
And then the nonprofit,
it really allows me
to do something that is more of a passion
that I think truly makes a real difference
in peoples' life and so it's
a good balance, you know?
Some people will say hey, why couldn't you
just find something that
allows you to do both?
Well if you can, great.
But you know, it's working
out pretty well for me
where I can sort of have both corporate
and nonprofit passion work.
And I feel pretty balanced.
- Yeah, and that's refreshing
to hear the reality too,
even though it sounds
like some people question
or give some push back.
But just know, you know,
there's different ways
to kind of bring those passions
and vocations together.
So that's encouraging to
hear how you've done that
in your own life, as well.
- Yeah, it's been great.
I mean, you know, you don't have to,
I think you don't have to necessarily try
to make your nonprofit or this passion
saying a full time job.
If you can, you should, but quite often,
it's a little bit challenging
in terms of the economics
the income, the compensation and so forth.
You can still do it
and you can still do it
and do it well, and maintain.
At least that's what
I've shown I've been able
to sort of do with my life and
I really like that balance.
Although I talk to people
who kind of feel like
well, hey, you know, if I could,
I would do this full time.
But it doesn't quite work
out in terms of, you know,
being able to pay the bills.
I'm like, well, just wanted
you to kind of have two.
You got two hands, right?
You're balancing a lot
yourself, right, Nii?
- I'm juggling a lot.
I don't know if I've gotten balance yet.
I mean, it kind of, I would
say it ebbs and flows.
And people often ask me that.
So it kind of depends on,
like even certain time periods
of the year, like, whether the research is
really the heavy emphasis,
whether some of the diversity, equity,
and inclusion work has a heavy emphasis,
whether the podcast, public-facing.
And so there's some flexibility
that comes there, too,
but like you, at this point in time,
it seems like it's the most effective way
to do thing with so many
different teams working
different entities, but.
- Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
- And it's definitely a
learning process, I'll say,
- Yeah, no-
- I haven't mastered it.
- I like the way you said it.
It's not balanced, then it's juggling.
I think you're right,
balancing (audio distortion)
Good call.
- One question that I didn't anticipate
or I would imagine some
people might be thinking,
you know, people who are
maybe trying to think
about nonprofit versus
something in the private sector
or in the academic sectors.
And listening to you talk
about how you're doing both,
do you ever feel like you have
to sacrifice one of the other?
- Yeah, wow, that's a good question.
Yeah, I mean, at times the demands are,
they're not always the same.
So there are times, I think, where I have
to work a little bit more,
especially with the nonprofit
because it's a volunteer thing.
I don't get paid for that,
so it's all just driven
in this belief, the belief
that I have in this cause
that mental health should
be accessible to everyone.
That what you could do despite your race,
your ability to pay, income, you know,
whatever identifiers you have.
But so there are times I think I have
to sort of work a little harder
to kind of stay energized
and then keep things moving
with our organization.
The work is the work, you
know, you gotta pay the bills.
Can't switch off on that as much, at all.
But I think there
certainly are times where,
in a sense like you have
to put a little bit more
than I probably would want to
to keep the work going with the nonprofit.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that's a healthy
and helpful perspective, too, you know,
for those who may also be
trying to think about that
or people who might be just
finishing up with school
and trying to think
about those next steps.
So definitely appreciate
you sharing that, too.
- Yeah.
- And like I mentioned,
we'll definitely lean
into your life's story as a
piece of your journey as well.
But before we get there, I
did want to ask a little bit
about just the nonprofit
and how that came about,
how that passion, you know,
in a sense, developed.
- You know, it's actually
tied with my story.
So I lived through a civil war in Liberia
and I mentioned, you
mentioned my sort of the book
"Liberia's Son", which was a collaboration
with a dear friend of
mine, David Verhaagen
or Dave Verhaagen telling that story.
But living through the
civil war, when I came
to the US in 1991, I didn't know,
as I started going to
school, I found myself
really fascinated by behavior
and sort of why I did the things I did.
And I'm not sure, like,
how many 15, 16-year-old
walking arounds sort of
asking those questions,
like, "Why am I the way I am?"
You know what I mean?
"And why are people the way they are?"
But I had that interest
facet or that fascination
and that led me to study
in psychology in college.
And then as I sort of
started to learn more
about this idea about
trauma and resilience,
and all of those things that come
with just a growing up and maturing
through difficult circumstances,
I saw a lot of value in mental health
and in mental and emotional wellness.
So I kind of connected with
some folks who were counselors
and therapists in the area and a group
of folks saw the gap in
access for mental healthcare
and they decided to
start this organization.
And I knew some of those
folks and gotten involved
through sort of the relationship we had.
And I've been involved since 2015.
And I think it started,
it was launched officially
and then probably a few
months later I got involved
and I've been involved since.
And it's just become
something that I truly value.
Mental health is one of those
things, I think you know this
better than me, that I
do, it's super important
but yet there's either low awareness
or there are just some hurdles to people
really engage in it and
seeing that as a critical part
of, I think Dr. Daniel Amen
calls whole body health,
spirit, emotional, mental, and physical.
- Yeah, that's beautiful to hear it,
just, I mean, the passion
and the drive there.
Obviously, that definitely
resonates with me.
And I am impressed that you were thinking
about that as a 15-year-old.
- Yeah, I dunno.
I must have got hit on the head
(Yu-Jay and Nii chuckling)
or something.
But it was just one of those things
that's always been fascinating.
I still see the world, interestingly
enough, through sort of
that mental and emotional
kind of health lens
in terms of behaviors and
understand sort of the root causes
go on below the water
line to see sort of what's
at the base of the
iceberg, as I like to say.
I think I find that really interesting.
- Yeah, that's so important.
And it seems like if you had,
I mean, you're just tying
together things you were
seeing in other peoples' lives
as you were here in the US, but then also
perhaps even reflecting
Black, reflecting back
on your own experience, as well.
- [Yu-Jay] Absolutely.
- I was wondering if you could just share
with our listeners as
much as you wanted to,
just your experience,
childhood experience,
both before the civil war and after.
And even before we go there,
I'll put in a little caveat
as the son of immigrants, as well.
But as someone who grew up
in the US knowing that these
aren't the things that are
taught in the US history.
So actually, if you can
also give our listeners
just a little bit of context
about the history of Liberia
and how things-
- Oh, yeah.
Oh, man, okay.
- [Nii] I know I'm throwing a lot out.
- Yeah, you always throw a lot.
You know, I've been in the
US obviously a lot longer
than I was in, probably two times as much,
as long as I was in Liberia.
But I still keep my Liberian card
anybody want to question that.
But Liberia was founded
by basically freed slaves,
so freed American slaves.
So at some point, after the
Emancipation Proclamation
and, you know, there were
people, there were a bunch
of folks who made the choice to go back
to resettle in Africa, and
they resettled in West Africa
and created this country
we know as Liberia.
The capital city is Monrovia.
Never was it an American
official sort of colony
but very strong ties with the US.
We speak English there
and it's not gonna sound
like English, if you
pull up, if we talked,
if I started talking in
my real Liberian accent
or if you're talking to a true Liberian.
But we definitely speak English.
Some of the values, I think,
of our country is American,
as you can imagine, because
the former slaves brought
those things there, some of
the food, some of the dress
and the style, and all those things,
so strong ties with the US.
Outside of Liberia, I think
the most Liberians I would say
are in American, in the US.
Childhood was pretty fun.
I grew up with my mom and my brother.
And then we had a lot of
sort of family around,
so kind of a true village mentality.
Every weekend seemed like
it was a family reunion.
You know, it's one of those things that,
and then here, you had
these family reunions
that are what, once or twice a year
because everyone is so spread out.
Every weekend, I mean,
the aunts, the uncles,
the grandparents all came and we just,
and it was just a wonderful village
for what a lot of love,
a lot of affection,
a lot of validation, a lot of affirmation.
Right outside of the city of
Monrovia went to private school
and went to one of the
better schools in Liberia.
So, you know, my mom
really was big on education
and so that was something
she sort of she pushed.
And as you can tell, it sort of stayed
with us even 'til now.
So you had a really good life in Libera.
I think I remember when
I first moved to the US
I really missed the life,
the pre-war Liberia a lot.
And it probably took me a couple of years
to really start to embrace
all the opportunities
and all the blessings of being in America.
But, you know, and things were
certainly different, not...
And then starting with the weather...
One of the things I remember
really sorta spooked me was
seeing kids with braces.
Just like, what?
That was just so bizarre to me.
I thought you guys had some aliens here
or something like that.
No, so braces really freaked me out.
But life was really fun in Liberia.
I enjoy my life growing
up and really thankful
for the family and the community we had.
And that love and that
support that I grew up with,
I think really became sort of
fuel for a lot of the things
that would come along later in my life.
There was real value in
growing up with a lot of love
and support, and
validation, and affirmation.
I think that gives you
confidence, you know.
And that, myself, that's
something that I...
There are lot of things
I wanna give my kids,
but just looking at
those things I mentioned
with love and affirmation,
and validation, I mean,
those are definitely the core things
I wanna give to my kids, you know?
'Cause you can teach
them how to make money,
how to do a lot of things, but I think
those foundational things
are really, ultimately,
I think what makes a big
difference in my opinion.
And that's really just
my opinion, of course.
- Yeah, no, that speaks volumes, as well.
And I think it's so
healthy for people to hear
about one, the history
because it's not taught enough
and just about the family
and community structure
that you had there.
And in some ways, I
know you're gone to this
in your book as you talk
about all the experiences
of the civil war from not really realizing
how serious things were to the realities
that hit at other points.
Even as you're talking
just now makes me think
about, you know, people like
to talk about resilience
and where that comes from
and whether it's biological,
but even as you were
talking and just thinking
about the structure and the support system
that you had from an early age
like that, that was just...
Like, I could just hear it in your voice
and in your comments about
how important that was.
And then it makes me wonder
what role that actually played
in your story overall, as well.
- Yeah, since I got more
involved with sort of
with understanding mental health
and especially with trauma,
'cause we lived through some
pretty difficult things.
So there was an interview
that I did on another show
with the person, and this
was with somebody I knew
and she said, "You know,
we never saw any sort
"of weird things about you guys
"being kids who had grown up in the war."
There was nothing weird where we thought,
"Huh, those guys are," you know,
they've been shaped somehow
by this traumatic experience.
And I think that was because we didn't go
through this alone.
My brother Jared and I, we
had this community around us
and I think that before
there were therapists
and you know, all these different tools
and resources we have
now around mental health,
people were going through difficult things
and surviving based on their
faith and the community.
And I think that, as I
look back, I realize,
"Oh yeah, we had those things."
That's why I can, you know, I'd be happy
to take any test, but I
mean, I've taken a few tests
to say I'm pretty okay, you know?
They're not loco, you know.
I'm not crazy or anything.
You know, kind of a normal person
but no sort of outsized
behaviors one way or the other
that at least that I've
been told of or anything.
But that community that I
mentioned was a big part of it.
And so, apparently that's,
and you maybe you know
this better than I do,
but it sort of strong faith,
strong faith community,
strong sort of supportive
community makes a huge difference
in how people weather
different storms in life.
- Yeah, no, that's definitely true
and it's encouraging
to hear you share that
from a real life experience, too.
I mean, the evidence
definitely points to that
when people are looking at things socially
in terms of things that have happened
in certain communities that, you know,
both in terms of negative
impacts it can have
on that community, but how
the community bonding together
can actually help navigate through that,
and then going all the way
back to the biology, as well.
I mean, even studies
which I've shared before,
that people have done in rodents,
looking at rats and mice.
If they're in community and they're going
through things together,
how those show empathy
towards one another is how some
of the biology's involved in that.
People talk about oxytocin
being one of those molecules
that's important for that,
and how that helps them
to actually navigate through.
So I mean, you can see that all the way
from the basic biology all the way up
to the clinical literature
and some of the community
based literature.
So it definitely makes an impact.
And even as we were talking
about faith communities,
as well, just even that first pass.
Again, a little bit agile,
but so many different stories
of just the importance of
having people to talk with
or experience those
things with and listen to,
just as that first pass.
Not even if people aren't,
maybe not even having quote-unquote,
counseling, certified counseling,
or a certified social worker or therapy,
but just that first step of listening
and then walking through,
like, there's so many examples
and evidence to how important that can be,
definitely help people
to navigate through.
- And I'm learning that more and more.
And I think over the years,
you know, talking to guys,
to folks like you and learning
it working with a nonprofit.
I think I'm getting what
I will call the language
to process the things we experience
and the things we had in our,
and, you know, sort of
living through a civil war.
- And how would you, I mean,
how would you say that's,
and I'm not sure I'm saying this right,
but how's that informing your
work with Psychology For All?
Even now, I mean, your own experience
and what you've seen, the
strength of the community,
how it's helped you through,
how does that inform what you do?
- Yeah.
- [Nii] Going forward.
- Yeah, I think it's
really given me a passion
for it now as I've gotten a little older.
When I first started doing
this, I think it was more
of a sentient interest in,
I have an interest in it
and doing this being
sort of being involved
with a nonprofit.
With Psychology For
All, it was an interest.
It was something that sort of made sense.
Something that was a good thing to do.
But now as I sort of reflect on my story
and my journey, it's become more of a,
it's become more of a
passion and more of a,
and I used the word other
ministry where I think it's...
You know, and then in the
faith circle you talked
about, sort of brokenness
and I see this opportunity
to be part of bringing healthy change
to some things, you know,
we might call, you know,
some broken areas in our
community and in our lives.
All the books I've read, all the therapy
and everything I've been through,
I always like to say this.
It started with I was patient
zero or whatever the term.
It wasn't about trying to fix anybody else
or changing anybody's lives.
It was more about okay,
I want to make sure
that I'm healthy, that
I'm bringing my best,
especially as a dad and
everything like that.
And then now I realize okay,
because I see the benefits,
I wanna be part of at least
making folks aware of it.
Obviously, everyone chooses
what they want to do.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, but it's definitely,
my story's become an
integral part of my approach
and sort of what shapes the lens
through which I see the work
we do at Psychology For All.
- That's great.
That's so important.
Also, I'm curious 'cause
I know that, you know,
some may be listening and
are feeling really encouraged
from hearing your story
and about the strength
of the community and
some of the resilience.
But others may also be thinking,
"Okay, well I know people who also went
"through difficult situations
"and maybe had that community
"and things still seem to
be difficult for them,"
or, "someone who went through
a traumatic experience
"and didn't have a good, strong community
"or felt isolated."
And so how, even knowing
your own experience
and what you've done so
far, what would you say
to someone like that in terms of some
of the access in mental health
advocacy work that you do?
- I think that, you know,
your community is really,
I mean, you get to kind of,
you came to know all ways
you can create your community.
Quite often, you think,
"Well, it's my family
"and the people sort of
within my neighborhood
"or my zip code," or if you're, you know,
if you're living somewhere, you know,
in certain places, your
village, your town, or whatever,
but what community is is
really more, you know,
for me and I think the people sort of have
the shared values and who
are gonna sort of walk
alongside you and support you.
And so if your community,
as it looks like right now,
isn't offering the support you need,
yeah, definitely I would
say expand your community.
One of the things that I had growing up,
and you may be familiar
with this, you know,
just a lot of mentors.
And I had, I used to say, I
would joke and I would say,
I had multiple mamas, so
different, you know, these,
some of your mom's friends
or there were women
who just where like to sort of take you on
as one of their son or
something; they were supportive.
Or mentors, you know, who
became part of that community
and provided some of that
support and that affirmation,
that accountability, and
all the things I needed.
So, my comment to those folks would be
to sort of expand your
community a little bit.
Go beyond sort of the confounds
of what your community looks like now.
And find those people,
you know, who can be
sort of the supportive folks.
And they're out there.
They are out there.
There're plenty of, obviously
there are organizations
out there that have mentors
and provide mentoring
services and other things.
But whether it's a church, a club,
you know, YMCA, you know,
different affinity groups,
a hobby, you know, there's
so many different places now
to find supportive community, I think.
But, I don't know.
- [Nii] That's good.
- I don't know if that makes sense to you
as in your profession, Nii.
- Yeah, I mean I think that's really,
those are really wise words, too,
especially as you defined it earlier on
that if that's not happening
within the community
people have already to
be able to and be willing
to look elsewhere, and to
be able to get that support
of people who have that like mindset.
So I think that's really, really important
that you shared that and
really, really helpful advice.
I'm also curious 'cause I
know you've mentioned faith
and faith communities,
as well, a few times.
So how is that, what's that
aspect of your journey?
What has that looked like
and how's that continue to play a role?
- Yeah, wow.
I don't know if we could
have survived the civil war
in Liberia, and we lived
through some pretty,
you know, pretty scary things
for a period of time there
in terms of just escaping firefights,
being held at gunpoints,
gunpoint, excuse me, a few times,
dealing with starvation
and food shortages.
I mean, there were a lot of scary things
but we always had our faith
in God and just in prayer.
And I've come to find
that the Bible's probably
one of the best, if not the best book
of mental health, actually, you know.
And this is, I don't know too many people
who would agree with that, but
as you sort of read the Bible
and really get to know the stories
and you think about the trauma that Daniel
and Shadrach, Meshach, and
Abednego, or David, or Joseph.
I mean, people went through some really,
and of course, Jesus himself, of course,
you know, some really difficult things.
And you see how those difficult things,
the ark of those things led to victory,
you know, (audio distortion)
or while they were still alive.
And I thought, and so those
things became sort of part
of how we lived our lives.
And yeah, it's a big part of
faith is, it's almost like
I can't see my life without my
faith in God, I really can't.
I mean, I'd be, you know, I
won't say because of my mom.
She probably doesn't like me to say that
so I might not be the
best Christian, right,
if I have to be honest with myself.
But I do believe and
whatever little faith I have,
I think continues to make
just this huge difference
in how I navigate the ups and downs,
and the (audio distortion)
of life, for sure.
- Yeah, that's really powerful.
I mean, I appreciate even the
way that you just framed that
even how you, you know,
read through the narratives
in the Bible and the mental
health ark that's there.
I don't think we always
give as much acknowledgment
or credit to as we should
about how difficult
a lot of those circumstances were.
And so that's really-
- Yeah, they seem like
stories but they're real.
And I admit it too, you
probably define yourself
in those stories, you
realize, oh yeah, okay.
Yeah, you can sort of go
through the same process
and come on the other
side and be resilient
and be a victor, and so forth.
- Yeah, really powerful.
And so may aspects of community
within those stories, as
well, even as you were talking
about in your own experience.
I mean, there's so many parallels there
and things that we can
definitely learn along the way.
And to push on that a little
bit, I know you talked
about your faith in God and just reading
through those stories, you
know, the practice of prayer.
How's the community of faith?
Has that also been part
of the journey, as well?
- Yeah, it's definitely yeah.
And as I mentioned, in Liberia, we had...
When we were living through the war
and well prior to that,
we were part of a church
and, you know, used to host
a Bible study at our home.
And so we had that community
and then (audio distortion)
when we lived through
the war, we still had
that faith community, so there were people
we could read the Bible
with and pray with,
and even just talk through
sort of the experiences
we were having and encourage
one another and that, okay,
"You know what?
"God can see us through this
"and we're just gonna
continue to trust Him."
Obviously, you know, some people made it
and some people didn't make it
and, you know, why that
happened that way, I don't know.
But we certainly, our faith
community really was important
and it was a kind of a perfect,
and I'll call it therapy,
or whatever, but to help us navigate
what was a very difficult time.
And that's become really
true even through now.
And, you know, I've had
other challenges in my life
for this house or family,
and I've been able to,
that faith community's always been there
to kind of give me the
strength to sort of see my way
through whatever the obstacles were.
- Yeah, again, just so powerful
and so brave at the same time.
I know, depending on when we're talking,
where we're talking
about faith, either here
in the US or different parts of the world,
it can look very different
in different situations.
And knowing that in some
situations, people are navigating
through a whole host of
challenges that sometimes some
of us in the states can't even relate to.
People who have had to become refugees
or take asylum because
of all these things.
And to hear, always to hear stories
of people holding on to their faith
in the midst of those
challenging situations.
And even as you mentioned,
not everybody made it,
but how that was such a
bedrock and a foundation
I think is so powerful and something
that I hope we're paying
more and more attention to
in general, but then also just in terms
of how it affects our lives,
how it affects our mental health.
And so, again, it's just
powerful, encouraging,
and sobering to hear you kind
of walk through those pieces
of your story, as well.
- Yeah.
That's cool.
- So I'm gonna pivot a little bit
'cause I know, and as you know,
we pull on a lot of topics
on this podcast and we're
getting to that already.
We've already talked
about some of the culture
and mental health, and faith.
But in terms of race,
that was another topic
that I wanted to kind of
talk through, as well.
Especially with everything that's happened
in the last few years,
but then also knowing
that conversations about
race are different,
different and overlapping in
different parts of the world.
So I'd be just curious if you'd share
with our listeners your
perspective on race
and race relations both
from the context of Liberia,
and for those of you listening,
Yu-Jay's smiling right now
so I'm sure he has a lot
to share both from the context
of Liberia and then the states.
And then, you know, there's
some comparisons we might jump
into later, even from my own experience.
But I'll leave it there for now.
- Yeah, you do that.
- Don't wanna open it up too much.
(Nii chuckling)
- That's some pretty heavy
(audio distortion) lift.
I'm thinking am I supposed
to dunk this thing
or am I gonna barely get
(audio distortion), man.
But, yeah, and so I will say
that in Liberia, we had tribes
which, and I know I don't think a lot
of people are familiar
with the idea of tribes,
but they're essentially just
subgroups within the country.
And we have different dialects
and we called 'em dialects
or you know, languages.
And you may have to add a better context
to some of this stuff here, but
I'm just gonna kinda explain
the way that I know it.
And so, my family was from one tribe
but we were all obviously
dark skin, Black people.
But there was, you
notices, there were sort
of stereotypes and differences based
on what tribes you came from.
And so I had a tribal context.
But then coming to the US, now you've got
a skin color racial
context, which is different.
And I grew up when I came
here, I sort of grew up
in a very predominantly white world.
And I have a friend of
mine who's jokingly said
that I was white socialized,
like yeah, I guess.
Okay, but you know, so
going through prep school,
prep college, and other
schools that were, you know,
there were not a lot of
Black and Brown people
and really enjoying those experiences.
I actually loved those experiences
and the values they sort
of inculcated me with,
and you know, so I have no regrets.
But it was not till college
that I really started
to understand myself as,
that I started to explore
myself as a Black man in America
and what that really means.
That was a relatively
interesting experience.
And I started taking, I took some
African American lit
classes and did readings
of Ralph Ellison, Derrick Bell,
and you know, DuBois
and all these different,
and then some Purnell,
West, and Henry Louis Gates.
I mean, like that's when I'd written...
That was, I was what, 19 years old?
And anyway when I started to kind of go
through this actually a self actualization
of oh, I'm a Black man in America.
That's different from being
a Black man in Africa.
I'm like Liberian.
And learning that and then
trying to sort of embrace that
and still be true to
the fact that I grew up
in what people might, I
mean, I call it American,
but people might call a white world,
and I was very comfortable in that space.
And I still am.
And then there's this Liberian part of me
that I value and you know,
I don't wanna lose either.
And so then there's the
African American side of me
so I never, I had to kind of realize,
I'm a multi-cultural person.
I never even-
- Yeah.
- Right?
Like, oh my goodness, I'm
a multi-cultural person.
So my feel on race is
it matters, you know,
kind of going from Cornel
West's book "Race Matters".
I think it was one of the
first book I read on race.
And it's important and I
think there's some beautiful,
you know, sort of distinctions
that I think makes
us as a community better.
It is hard for me to sort of
to kind of understand the
conflicts that we still see here,
you know, racially, in America.
It's something that I don't
know how much of it I,
you know, it's more kind of the lenses
through which we see the
world and how much of it is
the reality of the world.
Do you know what I mean?
There's a quote I saw not too long ago
from I think from the Talmud
and it said we see the world,
we see things not as
they are, but as we are.
And this idea of okay, what
is it that I'm projecting
to sort of what happening around me?
And then what is it that's actually true
in terms of my actual experience of racism
or discrimination or any inequity.
So I don't know if I
answered your question
but I thought my-
- Definitely.
- My perspective.
It's something that I'm
growing to more and more.
And to understanding and then hopefully,
navigating it in a healthy way.
- Yeah, that's so important.
I mean, that quote that you mention too,
then again, it just ties
everything together.
'Cause I'm thinking about
that both from culture
and race in terms of what
we perceive versus what is.
And how we don't, at
least you know, maybe,
perhaps just in the circles where I am in,
we don't have that
conversation, necessarily,
about race as much, but we definitely have
that conversation when it
comes to mental health.
I mean, in a sense,
that's at the crux of some
of the things that we talk about
when we talking about
things like depression.
What do you perceive and
how is that different
from the reality of the situation?
And what state you're in at that time?
But there's such an overlap there
and I think, you know, if
as much as we'd be able
to have that conversation
within the cultural context too
and then to be able to
question what we perceive
would actually allow us
to move to a better place
of understanding and healing.
- Yes, yes, absolutely.
- It would be easier said
than done, obviously.
- Well, but you know, yes,
you're absolutely right.
And thankfully, I think
there's more work being done.
I think there're more
conversations I would say
being, sort of being,
you know, had, I guess.
And so my general sense
is that the chains are,
you know, in terms like
a full born reality
we're moving the chains.
But you know, I think
there would be some people
would probably say, "No, we're not."
And they'll have their
reasons why they think that.
And I'll have my reasons
why I think that, too.
Why I think what I think, right?
- Yeah, yeah.
How does that tie in, 'cause
I'm also just thinking
about your nonprofit too,
and in terms of access,
how does that perception versus reality,
one, tie in to whether
people have access or not?
Two, I guess whether they
take advantage of that access?
And then, three, once they get there,
if the perception of them
is actually accurate.
'Cause there's a whole host of evidence
that people from Black and
Brown communities are put
into certain mental health
categories or diagnoses
much more often, whether
that's correct or not.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean a three-part
question, this is what-
- Let's go one at a time.
We'll just do the access first.
- Let's go, now I got, I got-
- I gotta slow down on the academic mode.
I'm throwing everything in at once.
(Nii chuckling)
- Well, I think that, you know, in terms
of access, you know, I believe
there are opportunities there
for us to drive more
access with mental health,
especially because of
lot of folks, you know,
the folks we serve, I mean,
the average income in $10,000.
And we so, you know, that there's...
I mean, therapy is really not cheap,
I mean, in my experience
and so driving accessibility
to those folks is important.
I think the perception
that maybe folks don't sort
of, you know, serving in
Black and Brown communities,
I think don't necessarily
want to be a part of this
and take advantage of these services.
I've found it's not exactly true, right?
You know, initially, I've heard there are,
I mean, I've seen different presentations
and read some things about stigma
and cultural biases and so forth.
We're seeing, and we're seeing in our data
sort of year over year
increasing utilization
of our services as
people are aware of them.
And I think that that was sort
of a perception versus reality, right?
- [Nii] Yeah.
- Well, and people just,
they don't want it,
people don't wanna take
advantages of the services,
they don't feel like they're needed,
they've got, you know,
whatever beliefs they have
in whatever communities that it happens.
But no, people want to be healthier
and I think maybe the
pandemic was a catalyst.
I don't know if there's...
I know that there's a
connection between the impact
between sort of the
pandemic and mental health.
I don't know if the, I wanted to say,
and maybe you know this more empirically
that there's a connection
between the pandemic
and people seeking mental healthcare.
I don't know that, but probably something
to look into, maybe.
- It seems that way just from talking
to those who are giving clinical services
in terms of the number of
requests that they're getting.
Just actually, definitely
had those conversations
with a lot of-
- Yeah.
Yeah, so I mean like, we saw that.
We saw that with some of our data.
But if access is just an
issue, equity in terms of...
I saw an image once
where it had three people
at three different
heights, basically standing
on the same kind of stool or whatever.
And it was like, well,
that's sort of equality.
But then it had, and they were
trying to look over a fence
at something and it kept.
Have you seen this before?
- [Nii] Yep.
- And then there was one
where, yeah, but then
you see the next image
where it's more equity where it's like,
okay, we're gonna sort
of adjust these things
so that everybody can actually see it.
Because even though we're
all on the same place,
I've got an advantage because I'm 6' tall
and there are persons who are 5'-4".
And that was really interesting
because it was a great
visual on how to think
about this idea of equity,
which we still have a lot
of opportunity to drive in our community.
And I'm talkin' about actually
broadly across the country
but certainly where I am
here, outside of Charlotte.
And so that's another opportunity.
And I think the perception
is that just because we,
you know, there's a sort of what seems
like an even playing field,
everything that's equitable.
Well, it's not, right?
That's something that I'm learning, too.
And the reality is it's not
and try to be part of solving that.
So hopefully, I hit on all three parts
of your question there.
- Yep, well I think, you
know, you got the first two.
The third one, which I
threw in as a curve ball
at the end was just, and
that's too many at once.
(Nii and Yu-Jay chucking)
- Go ahead.
- But just in terms of,
so I mean, in terms of
how people are assessed
or diagnosed-
- Oh yes, yeah.
- When it comes
to mental health, so where the,
I mean, that's a complicated
issue in and of itself.
I acknowledge that, but I was curious.
Any, you know, insights or
perspectives you have there?
- Well, let me say this, Nii.
I think everybody, Nii is the
professor, mental health guy.
I am more of a guy who
just finds this more of a,
some day, I'm interested
and I've read a few books.
And I just have more of
sort of a raw passion for it
so I'm not a clinician
or anything like that,
I just wanted to put that out there.
So anything Nii says, you probably want
to listen to it and not too much mine.
- We're gonna put them together.
- Yeah, put 'em together.
There you go, perfect.
You're a team player.
You know, I have heard and I've seen
that, you know, we have sort
of this disproportional rates
of, you know, especially
our kids being Kooken's
and this happening more or
less, well, more problems.
That is unfortunate because I think some
of that, if it's not done correctly,
I think it shapes the
individual long-term.
And I think what I've learned is
that those categorizations do have,
you know, long-term
implications and can imprint
in almost every trajectory of your life.
And that's what I've seen
in my, sort of my small sort of space
that I operate in here.
And I've read a few things like that
and I'm sure you can probably speak
to this a little bit more.
- Yeah, I think that's 100% on
and just from a scientific lens,
even though that's not
something I've studied
but have definitely read about,
just in terms of developmentally,
how important those,
let's, for a lack of
better words, say labels
at an early age can
actually impact expectations
and trajectory, again, taken
from a neuroscience perspective.
So I think, yeah, I think
you're exactly right.
And it's so important that we actually
one, pay attention to it,
and actually, you know,
do things to make sure
that we don't put those
things there initially.
But then I guess until
all the complications
about the biases that are in the system
or in our minds as
people, and how we do that
without even acknowledging,
and in some cases, realizing
in some case, not realizing what impact
that can have on the upcoming generation.
And I say that knowing
that my age is increasing
as folks seem to be younger.
But it's just so important.
I mean, more and more each day, I think
about the impact of,
you know, my own choices
or words, whether it's with my own kids
or kids in the community, or
souls that I'm talking to,
or college students, and
how much that that can...
Not that it's just on me, but each of us
who have those roles can
actually set trajectory.
So I think it's-
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, yeah labels, you know.
I mentioned "Race Matters", you know,
Cornel West's book, earlier,
and now I'm thinking maybe labels matter.
(audio distortion) labels matter
and they really can...
And I think, fortunately,
you know, going back
to my story, you know, that I had
the really healthy labels put on me,
you know, smart, kind,
you know, affable,
you know, those kind of things.
And loving and loved and all those things,
and I'm thinking that that has shaped,
again, where I am and the
trajectory of my life.
And as we're talking now,
I realize that I can think
of people who had different labels,
you know, stubborn, difficult,
pain in the rear, you know?
You know, and stuff like that.
And then you'll be surprised how people
sort of internalize those
things, probably subconsciously
and it shapes them.
That is a thing and in our
work, we have some leads
in terms of with the
nonprofit the screening
trying to, you know, making
sure that we're working
with therapists who are
credible and licensed,
and someone who understands
some of the nuances
of the community we work with.
We try to have good
representation of people,
whether it's bilingual
or sort of ethnicity again, and so forth.
- Yeah, I think that's-
- [Yu-Jay] It brings some sensitivity
to those (audio distortion).
- Yeah, I think that's so
powerful in a lot of ways.
And again, I know I said
encouraging about 10 times
in this conversation,
but just to hear the way
that you're paying attention
to so many different aspects,
I mean, both, you know,
hearing peoples' stories,
bringing in the mental health experts,
also paying attention to
the culture and background
and access aspects of faith,
so it's just, I think it's powerful
and something that I
hope will be replicated
in other ways, as well.
I don't now if that's something,
if you're been talking
to others in other
communities, or if there is
some long-term plans to
see this in other places
in the country, but anything
you'd be willing to share?
- Yeah, I think, you know, and
I know that one of the things
that's great about the
mental health space is
that the need is so great, so
they're, (audio distortion)
and they're aren't enough,
I don't think we have enough resources.
And then even where there are enough,
they're importing resources,
there's still a lot of opportunity
for us to sort of, to
be more interconnected.
I think that from what I've seen here
in sort of where we live, there's a...
The organizations that are
trying to tackle mental health
especially in the underserved communities
still seem to be operating in silos.
You know?
And so there is an opportunity
to drive better connection
which I think which will ultimately lead
to more efficiency, better care delivery,
and then ultimately, you
know, a better service
to the people who we're trying to help.
I would love to see
this Psychology For All
of that, the model that we use
where we don't have therapists who are
like, employed by us.
We have a bunch of
independents there who choose
to partner with us and accept our rate,
and then deliver those services to people
who can't afford it, who would otherwise
not be able to afford it.
And we've got people who
have rates of, you know,
$500 to people who are
rates are like $120,
but we pay a flat rate of $65.
And so we're not, our clients get to work
with, I would say the best.
It's not (audio distortion) some folks
who don't now us, they're,
man, I could say who don't
know what they're doin'.
But there are opportunities
and it would be great
to see, we need more organizations
but even more so need, I think
we need more connectivity
between organizations in
the mental health space.
Quite often, I think there's,
we got a lot of people
doing a lot of things.
But as someone who might
be looking for therapy,
especially if I'm
underprivileged, where do I start?
You know, I only know
of maybe what's end up
in my, you know, in my
community, whoever comes to me.
But I would love to see a resource
where you can just go
and look up, you know,
what you want by race,
ethnicity, specialty,
all these things, pull it
up and it doesn't matter,
you know, where people are and be able
to try to find services
to meet your needs based
on, you know, whatever
your specific, you know,
I guess, interests are.
- Yeah, that's huge.
I mean, even as you're talking,
you're giving me some ideas and thoughts.
So we're gonna have to
extend this conversation
in some ways and I think
there's actually folks
I'm gonna try and connect
you with, as well,
'cause I think that
would go such a long way.
And it's so needed in
so many different ways.
- Are you seeing that from your work
that, I don't know if I'm
allowed to ask you questions
but I guess I am, brother.
- You're good.
(audio distortion)
- Do you know, 'cause
I see this and I talk
to other people (audio distortion)
but I mean, you have a office,
a pretty large network.
Are you seeing some of
that sort of the silo
that's operating in sort of individual
(audio distortion) lens
versus sort of a collaboration
with another (audio distortion)?
- Definitely, I'm trying to be succinct
and not go on a hold.
- Yeah, sure, sure.
- So, I mean, it happens
across all of the spheres
which I talked about in terms of the work.
So I mean, this is a little bit of it,
but definitely within
the academic circles.
The silos definitely happen
between institutions.
They definitely even
happen within institutions.
That's where we're thinking about things
like diversity, equity, inclusion,
where things happening in silos,
things happening in parallel
and so a lot of the work
that we've been doing
in that role is trying to
just open up the conversation
to have more collaborative conversations.
But it's definitely happening
within the mental health spaces.
It's a challenge because
there are so many things
that are happening in individual
communities that are good.
But then as you mentioned,
someone might be
in a certain situation and
not know where to start.
So I do see things, you know, as I've been
in this work for the last few years
in different pockets and
different places of the country.
And those things are effective,
but it becomes a matter of how do you kind
of galvanize those resources
so that it's broader across the country.
And even broader for,
I mean, we talk about,
you know, things that
are important for those
of underrepresented backgrounds
or Black and Brown communities.
So seeing some of the things like,
I'm forgetting the name,
Therapy for Black Girls
in some of the organizations
but seeing, there's a lot,
there are a lot of larger organizations
but also a lot of smaller organizations
that could also benefit from
having those communities in.
So sometimes it becomes
many of us individually,
and this reinforces it, kind
of sending those resources
out to people we know,
but we still need a way
to have that be more global.
So again, you've got me
thinking in a lot of ways.
- Well, yeah, that's
definitely some that I have,
as a business person, you
know, I mean, you mentioned
I went to business school, UNC,
and got an MBA and I'm a business guy.
And I think just from
what, that's an opportunity
to figure out how to bring...
Say I had a skill, right?
'Cause you know, skill,
all the different services
that are out there, in
a way that allows us
to actually have greater impact, actually.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think that's well-said.
'Cause you know, at the same
time, I'm still thankful
for the work that you are doing,
that so many are doing
in different places,
but just like you put it,
to have even greater impact
and to be able to
collaborate across groups
I think is really, really important.
And I think, you know,
even to push that further,
small groups and some of
the large organizations.
So I mean, we've been fortunate in a sense
because, you know, coming
from a place like Yale,
sometimes gives us access to
some of those larger groups
that we can kind of
push those conversations
in those places, too,
to talk about, thinking
about aspects of cultural competency
or incorporating aspects of faith.
Even in the questionnaires
there's someone that's looking
for people from different
faith backgrounds.
So that's been encouraging
to see, but still,
still so much more that needs to be done.
- And it's what I call a good opportunity.
I mean, and I think
that it's a fun problem
to be part of trying to solve
because the impact is so significant.
I mean, you know this better than I do,
I mean, when you change one
person's life in a family,
you can also, the network effect of that
it's hard to quantify.
- [Nii] Yeah.
- [Yu-Jay] Yeah, so.
- Yeah, really well said.
Well again, thank you for
all the work you're doing.
And last thoughts you wanna
leave the listeners with
in terms of like, what gives you hope
on a day-to-day basis, or even things
that you can encourage them
to pay attention to going forward?
- Yeah, you know, it seems like
when you turn on the news now,
everything seems so unknown,
I'll say disparaging.
And so what I try to do, and I think
and I will say let's be proactive
about finding the good news
and finding the good sayings.
And it could be just, it could be some
of the same place things.
Like for me, just hanging out
with my kids is like, it's really fun.
I started playing pickle ball
which is
- Oh, wow.
- (audio distortion) born in America.
And just, you know, even getting out
and that's really fun.
But, yeah, you know, just be intentional
about finding things that
sort of bring you joy.
And put a smile on your face every day
'cause there's a lot that's sort of vying
to take, to give you the opposite feeling.
So, guess I'll leave you with that.
- Really well said, really well said.
I'm sure folks will take that to heart.
Again, Yu-Jay, just really
appreciate you taking the time
especially, I know you had
to move some things around
and just to create space.
So definitely appreciate you being here.
All the words of wisdom that you shared,
your honesty about, and your vulnerability
about your journey, and the resilience
in community that's been there.
I know listeners are gonna
really be encouraged by this
and hopefully spurred to
do some good work, as well,
from hearing what you've been doing.
- Thank you so much.
You know, I'm a big fan of yours.
I respect you, I admire your story,
and just respect my friend.
Thank you for the work that you're doing.
(upbeat music)